hello everyone scp-049 here I'm speaking  to you today with a purpose I would like  to know what games you would like to see  me play bear in mind I am restricted to  BC games as I like the recording  software to record anything else  ideally the suggestions should be doctor  or disease themed I'll say if you'd like  to see me play other games I would be  willing to consider it so if you would  be so kind as to leave your two cents in  the comment section that will read  through them and make the most uploaded  suggestion I think we'll make a good  let's play one more thing even though I  got lots of good things about a game  called five nights at freddy's i don't  think it's something that would be  entertaining to watch me play as the  reactions seem to be the main focus of  those Let's Plays and I'm sure as you  can see I'm not a very emotive  individual thank you all for listening  and as always I am The Cure  you